institutional demand for bitcoin has
gone bananas institutionals institutions
are looking at bitcoin more than ever
and uh we have some number here to
showcase exactly what we're talking
about so cryptoquant.com on twitter
released this chart earlier today it
says bitcoin under coinbase custody for
institutional clients increased 296
percent since q420 look at that chart
it's up and to the right from 17.072
believe that's in uh billions yeah the
unit is billions uh oh well of btc up
top too and then it increases all the
way up to 67. so we've seen a massive
increase nearly 300 percent increase
over the last year or two years uh for
institutional demand and custody of
bitcoin on coinbase i think this is a
trend that we're probably going to
continue to see over the foreseeable
future as the asset cost continues to
grow and what we've seen we have a bunch
of charts here also from uh from the
on-chain analysis side that show kind of
where the bitcoin is sitting today on
exchanges versus off exchanges and so
forth so if you
if we pull up the all exchanges bitcoin
uh chart i don't know if we have that
one but uh we can look at that later so
if you look at uh what's happening in
the market today though it's very
obvious that institutional demand has
continued to increase over the last few
years it's a bear market to some degree
now asset prices have obviously pulled
back more than 50 or so from the
all-time high and then if you think
about it in context of institutional
entrance this is probably pretty good
time for companies or institutions that
wanted to get in previously a large
percentage of the bitcoin market is
driven by institutional demand as much
as people want to hate on institutions
and say you don't need them et cetera we
see all time like the the dca chart is
up and to the right of small holders of
bitcoin they continue to dollar cost
average on an annual daily monthly
whatever it is basis just doing it time
over time again institutional demand is
where you really start to see the price
of bitcoin accelerate because they're
big buyers right they come in and they
can invest billions of dollars 100
certainly millions of dollars or
hundreds of millions of dollars if not
billions of dollars and that demand is
really what can make the price
appreciate given the supply of bitcoin
is fixed or at least constrained and
capped right now yeah but we saw that a
little bit with uh the tarot lunar stuff
where they were buying billions and
billions and billions of dollars of
bitcoin every single day it moved the
price a little bit upward based on
sediment but also based on just the
natural buying supply and demand side of
things right but institutional demand
institutions when they come in they're
going to come in hard right institutions
right now i think they have a lot of cap
on the they have a lot of capital
sitting on the side waiting to get
entrance into it they're waiting for
regulation they're waiting for these
services to be set up i know fidelity
has a ton of institutional stuff
coinbase has a ton of institutional
stuff um so a bunch of companies are
working on the institutional side and
they want that demand uh because they're
going to be the winners and those are
really the market movers like
you can buy 10 of bitcoin every single
day all you want but it's not really
gonna move the market um like these big
movers can like these big market makers
can they can go ahead and they can move
the price um up a lot or down a lot
right if they buy or sell and depending
on what they want to do yeah i think
it's naive to think that institutions
were just moving on uh there's certainly
some momentum-based traders and there's
people that are uh trying to time the
market and do different things around
actually trading the asset but then
there's a whole other subset of
institutions that believe in this asset
long term right and have been acquiring
bitcoin whether it's monthly or yearly
or whatever it is uh but have a
long-term outlook on it and if you're
one of those people that sees bitcoin
down now 60 plus percent from the
all-time high you can go in and start to
allocate more funds towards it because
you know that you're buying at a good
price relative to what it was at least
six months ago or 12 months ago even if
you think that was overvalued to some
degree given the market cycle and the
dynamics of the network it's still a
good price relative to what you were
buying at previously so whether it's
dollar cost averaging or just allocating
a large chunk of your capital towards it
i think what we're going to see is we've
seen this cycle play out now for
multiple times now multiple halvings and
i think that the best capital allocators
are looking at this as an advantage and
a time to actually go buy the asset
rather than run scared rather than tell
clients not to get interested or buy the
asset or so forth i think that what
we'll see is when we emerge from this
and we start to see the price appreciate
more there's going to be a bunch of new
capital allocators and institutional
investors that come out and have larger
positions than they previously had in
bitcoin yeah but what do you what do you
take into account on coinbase the amount
uh it increased 296 from q4 of 2020. but
we saw obviously a giant price increase
in 2021 we saw this institutional demand
go down and then here you can see the
balance on exchanges that you were
talking about there um how it's just up
and to the right um and then has a small
downtick after 2020 actually yeah and
and look those uh it crossed right the
the balance on exchange and then the
price crossed in 2018 in 2021 and now
we're sitting down below uh what is that
2.5 million right so the balance on
exchanges has increased dramatically
obviously over the last few years but
we're also down a considerable amount
from what we saw at the peak in
2019-2020 people have moved their
bitcoin off exchanges and so forth and i
think it's an interesting dynamic to
continue to watch in the space because
of the impact that that can have on
price right if bitcoin is not available
for sale if people are removing bitcoin
from exchanges and doing other things
with their bitcoin
that helps right all you got to think
about is supply and demand and if the
supply is fixed or constrained we know
there's only ever going to be 21 million
certain percentages lost or stolen or
whatever it is new entrance into the uh
new uh
mining's taking place every single day
et cetera then we're going to have this
dynamic at play where if the
institutions do eventually come right
like there's you know people make fun of
the saying institutions are buying
bitcoin institutions for coming whatever
in every single market but i think it's
obvious that that's a big point of the
potential price appreciation in the
asset right you have a core base now of
people who are just dca every single day
whatever it is but the institutions play
a huge role and i think people are naive
to avoid that part of the conversation